so I guess the last time um Masha talked
about
um on deep learning uh the introduced
deep learning new networks and today we
are going to talk about back propagation
which is probably the most important
thing in deep learning like how do you
complete a gradient and implement this
algorithm of course there are many other
kind of like decisions you have to make
um in deep learning and also they are
um like a like this kind of like back
propagation this Computing the gradient
becomes kind of standardized these days
like you that don't necessarily have to
implement your own like a greeting
computation process where you can just
order the gradient is done by the
so-called Auto differentiation algorithm
but this is actually the only
algorithmic part in deep learning so
that's why we still teach it and also in
some sense it's still important because
um this idea of computing gradient
automatically you know actually has many
implications in other areas for example
suppose you want to study the so-called
Knight learning I'm not sure why you
heard of this word like which is
basically built upon this idea that you
can do auto differentiation for almost
any computation you want and and this
kind of same ideas also shows up in
other cases and also I know that um some
of the previous courses right also
covered uh the back propagation I think
cs221 does cover back propagation in
some sense so what I'm going to do is
that
um so in in the past and you know like
in the last four years when I teach this
you know I have a lot of derivations you
know with all of these indices and you
compute the gradient of you do the
change in very detailed way and this
year I'm going to try a slightly
different approach where I'm going to
make this a little bit of more packaged
in some sense like kind of divide into
kind of like a sub modules
um in some sense it's a little more
abstract in some other senses you know
it's it's cleaner because you don't have
to deal with all the small indices like
like all the like sometimes there are
five minutes is like you have to keep
track and now everything is kind of in
Vector form
so and and this is not like entirely new
it's not like I'm just doing experiment
because in the last time I did both of
the two versions right I have the the
very fine grain kind of like derivations
I also have the vectorized form
um and I think I got some feedback from
you that the the fun good derivation is
not that useful because
either you know you you feel like it's
kind of messy and I'm doing all of these
computations like on the board and you
kind of know how to do it it's very
messy or if you haven't seen it before
it's kind of hard to follow right so so
if you haven't seen all of them like if
you haven't seen kind of bad propagation
at all like even for a very very simple
case
um and you want to do the the very kind
of like a low level stuff I'll probably
take a look at lecture notes afterwards
you know like a look it's kind of like
independent what that teach here doesn't
depend on anything there doesn't require
any background but but it's it's more on
the a little more abstract level to some
extent like I would say it's more like
on the vectorized level so everything is
true as vectors so if you want to do the
more low level details you know you can
take a look at the lecture notes which
which I think that those part is a lot
easier and and mostly covered by some of
the other courses as well so that's why
I'm making this decision you know don't
don't worry if you don't see anything
like if this my comments doesn't make
sense here just you know if you haven't
seen any bad propagation so this is this
this I'm I hope at least uh this is
still like a very like the materials I'm
going to cover today still is completely
fine if you don't have you haven't seen
anything about
um bad propagation
um
okay so
um okay so let's get into the uh more
details so I guess um so basically the
so-called back propagation
this is just a
a word that describes
um like it's a terminology in some sense
back problem that
um is a kind of a technique for us to
compute a gradient of of the loss
function for Network so recall that last
time I think we talked about this you
know
um um like you have a loss function for
example you have a loss function J of
theta which is maybe let's just look at
one example J subscript this is the Lost
function of JS example and
um
and this is something like y j minus H
Theta x j
square right so this loss function can
be other loss function here I'm just
only using the square loss for
Simplicity and this is a new network
and recall that you know we talk about
ICD stochastic winning descent in when
you do deal with new artworks you always
have to compute this gradient so the the
algorithm is something like this
right minus Alpha times
J
um the gradient of the loss function on
some particular example J K maybe a
random example
um at the parliament Theta so basically
today what we're going to do is that so
basically today
how to compute this
a gradient
so this is the the main thing today
and once you know how to compute these
gradient you can implement this
algorithm and there's a generic way to
compute a gradient so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to start with a with a
very generic theorem and the theorem I'm
not going to prove it you know it's you
don't have to know how to prove it
but but I think it's kind of good to
know the existence of this here
so the theorem is saying that I'm going
to write down a statement but a theorem
is basically saying that if this loss
function J by the way I'm going to focus
only one particular example today right
because if you know how to compute the
gradient for one example then you know
how to configure green for all the
examples they're all the same so so the
point is so and the theorem I'm going to
write down today is that if you know how
to compute the loss itself
like in your efficient way then in
almost all situations you know how to
compute the gradient of the loss
and in a almost same amount of time it's
kind of like a very in some sense you
know if you heard of it the first time
it's kind of striking
um so let me let me write down the
theorem so I need to First specify some
of the Minor Details which don't matter
that much
um so anyway this theorem is going to be
stated somewhat informally so so let me
Define this so-called notion of
um differentiable
um circuits
or these differentiable Networks
so and
um and let's say this a differential
circuits or differentiable networks are
compositions
of
sequence
of let's say
um arithmetic
and arithmetic
spelling it correctly sorry operations
and Elementary functions
by the way my definition here is kind of
like a little bit hungry as you can see
but the point is you know you will see
the point the point is not exactly about
the the details it's more about the the
form of the theorem so by arithmetic
operations Elementary functions I kind
of mean that for example things like you
know
um maybe
addition you know subtraction you know
product you know Division and and some
of the elementary functions you can
handle you know actually most of the
elementary functions you can handle so
maybe cosine sine so and so forth
right exponential log
logarithmic maybe relu maybe sigmoid you
know there are many many of these
functions right so and suppose you have
this is my definition of differential
circuits or differential networks or
differential networks and you can see a
new network is often one of this right
because it will have a new network we
have a lot of Matrix specifications and
it's really just no matter how many
Matrix modification you have it's really
just some complex conversations of all
of this you know like operations right
so it's in some sense everything you
compute you know are some combinations
of these things right no matter is
whether a new network or something else
okay but but I'm going to insist that
they are differentiable because you know
I'm going to have have to I'm going to
differentiate on the output of this
network so here is my theorem
um
so
[Music]
maybe I should be I think the blue color
is a little better right is that right
okay so
um so and this is informally stated
no it's not very far from the formal
version like it's just a formal version
requires some
um some minor details about the
differentiability so and so forth so
like the claim is that suppose
you have a differential circuit
[Music]
of
say size
and
and means how many kind of like basic
operations you are using so this is my
size the size means the number of basic
operations and suppose this circuit
computes
computers a real valued function
so I'm going to stress this this is a
real value function
of that Maps let's say l dimension to
one dimension
um I'm going to stress that this theorem
only works when you have one one output
so like the function currently have one
output but it can have multiple inputs
so then
suppose you have such a circuit then
the gradient of this function that you
are computing
the gradient
so what is the gradient the gradient at
an important is a vector because you
have IO odd inputs where the gradient is
L dimensional right so so the gradient
is an L dimensional vector
the gradient at this particular Point
let's say x x is just the abstract point
and this can be
computed
in
time
time off and
um
I think
I guess technically this is O of M plus
d but I guess um
um
I'm not sure why I'm on my nose this is
typo I think
oh I see so okay I guess time off and
by
our circuit
of size
often
and here I have a implicit assumption
because you know implicitly
assuming
like is bigger than D because if n is
not less is less than D it's a little
bit sorry a is bigger than l
because you know if you have a circuit
the circuit if it you know most of the
circuits should read
like all the inputs right so so you
probably need at least an hour time to
read all the inputs so that's why I'm
assuming n is bigger than L if n is not
bigger than L then this has to be
slightly change changed but the the
message doesn't change so okay anyway
what's the main message the main message
is that if you can compute a function f
by a circle of size n then its gradient
can also be computed in a similar amount
of time and and you just pay a constant
Factor more and I think this constant is
literally in most cases this constant is
just one uh of course when you really
talk about the absolute constant it has
to depend on how some of the small
details like how to really implement
this you know in the computer so so
that's why I'm hiding a constant but in
some sense you can feel you can view
these Concepts even one
um
so
um okay I guess okay sorry um I think
whether the concept smart I think also
depends on how do you count right so
whether you assume you know you are the
computer function f so maybe okay so so
basically the constant would be two if
you
have to compute F and The Greener five
right so so basically there's a so if
you know the function f already then
this constant would be one if you don't
know the function f then you have to
first evaluate F and then do the
gradient and then this constant will be
two I'll I'll discuss this a little bit
uh later as well but anyway for the
moment you can just think of this you
know you almost have the same amount of
time you can only use the same amount
amount of time to complete the gradient
so gradient is never much difficult more
difficult than Computing the loss itself
so and and this is very general because
it doesn't have to be a new network
right it could be any almost anything
like this
[Applause]
so and if you want to you know
instantiate the serum you know for
um for new artworks of the lots of
networks then F you know in this theorem
what correspond to the loss function on
a particular example J J's example and
and Theta is the the variable acts here
right so and the gradient of f
corresponds to the gradient of the loss
here
right so and and what is the what is L
right so L is the number of inputs to
this function f so here what is the
input what's this variable in a car
about the variable care about is the
parameter Theta so L is going to be
equals to corresponds to the number of
parameters
and an n
so what is the the time to compute
um this loss function
the time to complete a loss function is
kind of like the same as the number of
parameters so if you think about you
know you have a new network of you know
a million parameters and how much time
you have to use to compute the final
loss function where you basically have
to give your input to your network and
go through the entire network and do all
of these operations and basically
eventually the amount of time you have
to spend is also similar to the number
of parameters
for evaluating the loss but only is the
time to evaluate the loss so that means
that the time for the gradient so
Computing gradient also takes
according to the theorem this also takes
off on time
so basically
you only have to take all of number of
parameters time to configure it
any questions so far
like how is the dimension of the input
already so
um they sound pretty different possibly
so here my does that depends on how you
map the apply the theorem to to this
setting so here I'm going to view this
as a function of the parameters
so the parameter is my input to this
function I'm going to differentiate with
back to the inputs right so so the the
theorem generation is a generic theorem
right so like there's some function and
you are differentiate with respect the
input of the function right it depends
on how you use this theorem so if you
use this theorem you say the Theta
corresponds to the X there
right so then what is L I always
dimension of the the X right there so so
L is dimension of the Theta here
any other questions
okay so I guess the the plan for the
next rest of the lecture is that we're
going to show you how this works for
Newark works I'm not going to show you
for the how this works for our general
circuits
um it's actually not much more different
different if you do it for the general
circuits but it's just like the whole
thing is um you need to have a lot of
dragon to really do prove this like with
the general circuits because you have to
consider how that all the generalities
right so so basically I'm going to show
the concrete example formula it works
how do you complete a gradient
um and and when you see the the concrete
examples for the right works you cannot
see how you do it for the for the for
those for General circuits
um which I'll probably discuss you know
if I have time at the end
and
um another thing like before I talk
about the theorem here
um I guess I like to say that this is
also this theorem is also the basics for
many of the so-called second order
method
so so basis
and also for example for meta learning
I guess we haven't introduced meta
learning but I think the point that the
product is kind of relevant is that
um
um so like I'm actually I'm not going to
talk about what my learning is in this
course just because it requires
um it requires um uh more kind of like
um backgrounds but but the general idea
is that you can use this
um serum twice so that you can do
something about a second order
derivative
but there is a there is a um there's a
specific setting you can do so basically
I think let me just give you a sense on
what I mean here this is not kind of
like a compared comprehensive because
sometimes you're going to use these
theorem in different ways but this is
one way to use this serum in a clever
way to get something more than what it
offers so
um so for example suppose in the same
setting
foreign
[Music]
you can claim that for any vector v
of
Dimension L this is the same as your
input dimension of x
then this
the hyacin
the second order derivative which is a
matrix this is a
i o by L Matrix
times this vector v
can be computed
in
of n plus L time and that's I guess I
said only is kind of like bigger than l
so this is still kind of like an often
type
so so you can see that this is kind of
like you know now it's kind of a more
magical right because if you come on to
compute this Matrix
typical it takes even just to memorize
this Matrix right even you just want to
kind of compute each entry in suppose
each entry of this Matrix takes off one
time then you always find L Square time
to complete this Matrix
so so certainly
if you want to do to to get all of n
plus L time your algorithm cannot just
first compute this Matrix and then to
take the Matrix Vector product that will
be two inefficient because just
Computing this major itself will take L
Square time
so however
um if you compute the whole thing
without going through without doing the
Matrix first and then take the Matrix
Vector product and complete the whole
thing all together then there is a way
to speed it up and you can do it in all
of In Time
well and it's bigger than L basically
right so basically you just take off and
type
[Music]
right so Newton's method you know
depending on which Nutri you're talking
about the the vanilla Newton's method
requires this Matrix
then it's l Square time
so we only know how to do Matrix Vector
python Vector product
so so so that's why I think you know at
least there are a bunch of papers in the
last few years which tries to implement
the original Newton's method without
Computing the hesit so they try to use
the highest and Vector product to have a
different way to implement original
Newton's method and and that you know
was somewhat successful you know like I
think you have you can have some new
some algorithms that tries to only use
the highest inductor product
um to to implement the approximate
version of the Newton's method
right so and and actually this you know
this corollary
um is actually pretty easy to prove and
and uh and and when you prove it you
know you can see how it's actually
the proof also tells you how to
implement this so
so basically you know like uh um
um the way to prove it is that
you just say I'm going to Define new
function G of x
this new function is going to be
the gradient times V
so this is a real valued function
because this is a function that Maps
all dimensional Vector to a real Vector
you know if the output is a real Vector
even though you have like there's some
it's sorry the author is a real value
scalar right even though these are
vectors you take the inner part that
becomes scalable
and then
so if you use the theorem so
by the theorem you know that g of x
can be computed
in of and type
just because you know the ingredient can
be computed so that's why after the
ingredients you take the inner product
you spend another of an of an actually
of n plus L time just to be precise
because you know computer gradient Takes
Over N time and then Computing the the
the the the inner Paradox L time you get
all of n plus L Type
and then you use the
use the theorem again
Ong G
so before we are using the serum on F
and you say the number F can be computed
now you're going to use the theoremong G
so you view G as the new F right so you
you view the f as the what's the right
way to say it like like a like so this G
will be the F in the theorem right then
you verify whether G is satisfy the
condition that's true because G can be
computed in all of n plus L time
and then that means the number of G can
also be configured in
it can be also be computed uh of n plus
L10 right so this means that novela G
also
computed can be computed
in of n plus L time
because you can do this twice right and
what is the the nubla G like the
gradient of G of x
if you do the computation
what's the gradient of this it's really
just you take another gradient here
um I guess this probably requires a
little bit you know you can verify this
you know using turn rules offline but
then the gradient of G is really the
gradient of the inner product of f x and
V and this is actually the Hyacinth of f
x times V
foreign
and and you can do this kind of things
like for many other things where you for
example if you define any functions of
the gradient
you can still to take the derivative
right for example I think in my learning
sometimes you have to have of maybe some
special function of the gradient and you
have to take another gradient of it and
that's that's sometimes you know a some
module used in metal learning and then
you can apply this again where you can
say okay this because the green is
computable in often time this function
probably just a very simple function so
the whole thing can be computable in
often time and then you can take another
derivative again
so so that's that's when you know I'm
not going to go into more details but
that's how people are using using it in
metal learning as well
so okay anyway so this part is Advanced
material we're not going to test it in
any of the exams or homeworks but just
uh I feel like this is a good to know uh
to some extent
um just because this uh this is used in
many other more advanced situations
any other questions
Okay cool so I guess now next I'm what
I'm going to do is that I'm going to
um
discuss a concrete case right in right
work I'm going to start with two layer
Network and then I'm going to talk about
deep new
Nets and um and basically I'm going to
apply the auto differentiation right the
the proof of the theorem is basically
you have to give Auto differentiation
algorithm or also called back
propagation so so um basically apply the
back propagation to the specific
instance right new Networks
Okay so
I guess so let me set up
some
um
so before talking about your artworks
maybe let me briefly discuss a
preliminary
this is the chain rule
I'm somewhat assuming that this is
covered in most of the Calculus class
um but I'm gonna have to review this in
here partly because I'm going to have
potentially different locations from
what you you know not exactly the same
notations from what you learn from the
calculus cost you know just because
different calculus book has different
notations so
um
for the purpose of this course what I'm
going to do is that suppose I have a
suppose J
is a function
of
Theta 1 up to Theta p
I'm trying to use as close notations as
our final use case even though this kind
of like this part is supposed to be
abstract right so all the notations are
just some symbols right I'm trying to
use similar notations just to avoid too
many confusions
so suppose FJ is a function of a bunch
of parameters a bunch of like a
variables and then
um suppose you have some intermediate
variables Suppose there is a
um
okay so how does this function works
this function works by
um by
I guess maybe what is the
this function is defined in this
following form so you have some
intermediate variables
so maybe let's say they are J1 which is
a function of
that
the inputs Theta 1 up to zero p and also
you have up to j k
which are J some functions of
so I guess you know I'm not sure whether
this farmers make any sense so I'm kind
of using the j i
I suppose the function
or under the variable of the of the
output of a function I think this is
pretty kind of like typical in emotional
math books right so so you can view J as
a variable and then this J is a function
of the state of up to Theta p and which
function it is you just use J1 to
describe that function
so
um
does it make sense
like yeah so and then just because I
don't really necessarily care about
exactly what the function is so I'm just
going to give a name and this name you
just call the same thing as the variable
so and then your J is a function of you
know
these intermediate variables
so and once you have this kind of like a
two-layer setup then suppose you care
about the derivative the chain rule is
saying that
if you care about the the partial
derivative of the the final output with
respect to some input Theta I
then how do you compute this derivative
you can do the chain rule so what you do
is you say you're going to enumerate
over all intermediate variables
so take the sum over J from 1 to K
and for each intermediate variables you
first compute the derivative which is
back to the intermediate variables and
then you multiply this derivative
with the derivative of any mini
variables with respect to
the variables you care about Theta I
um and just to clarify the dimension so
this is in R and everything is in
everything is a scalar so far
so
okay so this is the the chain rule just
uh in
in the language of this course
any questions
okay so now I'm going to
talk about a concrete case and uh
and maybe let me also Define some
notations so
um so
so maybe one important thing to note is
that every time at least in the context
of this course every time you have this
partial derivative thing like we insist
that the this quantity the quantity on
the top is a real valued function so so
we are not considering anything about
multi-evaluate outputs not because you
know you cannot consider them it's more
because you know
typically in machine learning if you are
taking derivatives derivatives
of a material outputs uh function
multivariable function a computational
is kind of like a it's a problem so
um so so so so so so in some sense I
think in the machine learning people try
to avoid that like at least at least on
the algorithm level of course in
analysis probably you have to think
about that that notion but on the
algorithm level you always like 90 of
the time you always try to
take derivative of a real valued
function you never try to take
derivatives of multi outputs
multivariable functions
and in this course we only have to think
about the case where this is a real
value function so that's why in the
notation so the notation here is that
so suppose J is a real value function
valued variable or function
then
um of course it's kind of clear what
what this would mean by so if you take
this with back to some variable Theta
that just means the partial derivative
that's easy but what if you have a
vector so suppose if
a so this is easy this is just a so if
Theta is a real value of vector this is
just the partial derivative which is
easy and what if a is
is it the green one is not great maybe
I'll use the black one so if a is a
some variable in dimension d
then uh
then this would be also in dimension D
that's our notation I'm just clarifying
the dimensionality right so and and if
so basically this would be just a
a collection of
scalars you know the partial derivative
of J with respect to A1 up to the
partial derivative of J with respect to
a d
which is dimension d
and we are also gonna we are also going
to get into the situation where
a is a matrix
maybe a is a matrix of D1 D2 and now
what does this notation mean becomes a
little bit tricky because sometimes in
different literature they are a little
bit different
um
on conventions for this um course what
you want to do is just that this has the
same shape as a so this is also this is
just a
um all the partial derivatives
and
and this is in the same as this has
exactly the same shape as a itself so
basically in in this course notation the
the this kind of derivatives or gradient
whatever you call it right so they
always have the same shape as the
original variable
um
all right
Okay so
um I think I need to
okay so now let me talk about the
two layer Network
this is just a review
I think Masha has talked about this so
um so you have something like
so if you the loss function is evalued
by the following so if you evaluate the
loss function what you have to do
you have to first compute the uh the
output of the model and then you compare
with the label and you come to a loss
right so basically the computation to
evaluate loss function is the sequence
of operations so you first compute the
so-called intermediate layers
um by doing something like this this is
the first layer weights times the input
on the data times plus some bias
variables
and say let's say this is of some
Dimension and
so and then you apply some
anchovies value
and you still maintain the same
dimension
and then you apply another layer maybe
let's say another layer that's called o
the output of the null layer is called o
so you apply W2 a
plus B2
and this layer because the output this
is the output layer so you want to make
this one dimensional so you get R1
um and often sometimes this is called H
the Del facts right this is the model
output
and then you compute a loss the loss is
something about half times y minus o
squared by the way I'm here only having
one example X and Y X is the input Y is
the output
okay so that's just a quick review of
the two layer networks I think
I'm quite sure that we are using the
same notation as measure
um hopefully so
um okay so now the question is how do I
compute the gradient with Vector
W1 W2 B1 B2 bye
in general how many of the samples
for all of them or like
that's another layer right so so that's
when you that's about how you implement
this algorithm right so if every time
you just like take one example you just
have to do it for one example if every
time you take a batch then you have to
do it for a batch
but uh for the purpose of this this
lecture you know this is a good question
but for the first of this lecture uh we
only have one example because eventually
you just do all the for all even you
have like 10 examples do all of them the
same way you just repeat the calculation
of course you can parallel parallelize
all the com the gradients of all the
examples but the the method is the same
so okay so how do I complete the
gradient of of this right like the
greeting of the loss with respect to the
parameters
so
so what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to
um
oh no this is uh yeah this is a variable
called o uh I think I probably should uh
how do I yeah I should change the notes
yeah like this is fine in the latex
right like but uh
how do I write this like so that it's
not look like a zero
um
I think I think I think it's okay to
let's see so is there any chance that I
can do it on the fly to change the
notation I think I should be able to
what what you want me to change it to
uh
Sigma is going to be used it's going to
be used for some other things
tall okay
but but just just this will make a
introduce some inconsistency with the
notes because in the nose this is all
just to let you know okay
um but I probably should change that in
the notes as well
yeah and also like you you see that this
one doesn't show up that often hopefully
okay so um so what I'm gonna do is that
I'm going to
um
um try to use some chain rule
um with this right so how do you chain
rule so
um for example you just if you just look
at one entry of this Matrix right this
is the Matrix you look at one and two
you can use the chain rule to derive the
the derivative of that entry so that's
the typical way that we do it you it's
going to be a very complex formula but
you can still do it right so you you use
the chain rule multiple times and then
compute the derivative of that entry and
then eventually you get a lot of
formulas and then you try to regroup
those formulas into a nice form
so that's that's actually written in the
lecture notes you know if you're
interested you can look at them
um it's pretty much a sprute force
computation
um of course if you do that Brute Force
computation multiple times then you get
eleven
like a little bit kind of like
expiration you can do it faster in the
future so
um what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to try to keep everything as a
vectorized notation and and still I'm
going to chain rule but I'm going to do
a more kind of like a vectorizing
version of the chain rule
so so because of that I'm going to have
this kind of abstraction so
so this is uh in some sense I call this
chain rule from Matrix modification
I guess there's no unique name for this
this is just a
um invited by me
but it's really a simple fact
so
so I'm going to um suppose
so Z is equals to W Times U plus b
where let's say
so w is a matrix of Dimension I say I'm
by D and U is a vector of Dimension T
and B is a
you know you don't have to do really
necessarily care about the dimensions
because you know the at least as long as
they match then it's fun so and then I
have some function applied on top of Z
so
so this is my abstraction right so you
can see this is a little bit like this
right because if you map this Z to this
Z and this W1 to this W and X to U and B
to B12
uh B1 to B then it's kind of like that
it's a kind of abstraction of a part of
the problem
so
um and then I'm going to claim that then
the derivative with respect to the W
which is what I care about
at least if you map it back to here we
talk about derivative derivative with
respect to w
so then this is going to be equals to
what is equal equal to
a derivative with respect to j z
times U transpose
and maybe just to kind of like um make
sure you are convinced that the notation
the dimensions match so this is supposed
to be
in R to the m by D because the
derivative as I said should have the
same Dimension as the original variable
W so w is in M by D then this is M by D
and this is in
RN because Z is a m-dimensional vector
so that's why this is AR and this is
um in our
1 times
d right because U is of Dimension d and
a new transpose is of Dimension One by D
I guess all the vectors are column
vectors so if if it's R I know
dimensional Vector it's really M by one
so all the vectors in this course is
column vectors
so so that's why this whole thing
uh
kind of match Dimension right because
this is a column Vector this is the row
Vector you take the outer product of
them you get a matrix actually this is a
rank one Matrix that's an actual
interesting observation the gradient
with respect to the rate Matrix for one
example is always a rank for Matrix
for one example not for all the examples
no not for the the full grid if you just
have one example the gradient for the
weight Matrix is typically one quad
Matrix
and
if you look at and also we know
the gradient
with Vector B is going to be equals the
gradient with respect to Z
so
this doesn't solve everything because
you still don't know what what this
quantity is right this quantity is
unknown here and this is going to the
same content here is unknown but but at
least it solves the local part right
it's kind of like chain rule right it
says that if you want to derived take
the derivative we'll explain to W then
you only have to know the derivative
derivative with respect to intermediate
variable Z and the next next I'm going
to talk about how to take the derivative
with back to Z so but this is kind of a
decomposition right so it says that if
you want to know the the derivatives
with derivative with respect to W then
you only have to know the derivative
with vacancy
um this is just what the formula tells
me
um but I'm I'm but here I'm verifying
that it does make sense because this is
a one by D Matrix one by D vector or one
by the Matrix and this is I'm the
national Vector of M times 1 dimensional
Vector because I view all the vectors as
column vectors so that's why I'm by 1
times 1 by D will give you m by D why is
the transpose that just because
oh I think the fundamental reason is you
do the calculation is exactly this
um but but it just happens to match you
know it has to match if the calculation
is correct right
right so and also you know maybe that's
a reasonable way to memorize it you have
to make the dimension match so that's
why it's the case so um
okay how do you prove this so
um proving this you have to go low level
you have to do it for every entry so I'm
going to show it once and then later I'm
going to have more abstractions like
this and I'm not going to prove it for
you so for this one I'm going to do a
quick proof
um it's really just a derivation so
so what you do is you just use the chain
rule
so
so what you do is you look at the
derivative derivative with respect to
any entry wij
so and how do you do this you say you
use the the most basic version of the
chain rule you you Loop over all the
possible intermediate variables so what
are the intermediate variables these are
these right sounds like it's very nice
to use Z as the intermediate variables
so I'm going to Loop over all possible
intermediate variables K from 1 to M
um and each of the ZR is one of the
intermediate variables or z k
so
DJ over dzk and then d z k over d w i j
right and then I'm going to plug in the
definition of decay so
so then this uh what's the definition of
c currency case there's um it's defined
by this message specification what is
the case dimension of here it's the case
dimension of this the case dimension of
this is going to be something like the
definition of Matrix fabrication wk1
times U1 plus W K2 times U2 up dot until
w
KD times
UD plus this P the b k
and you look at the partial derivative
of this with respect to w i j
so how to do this it's kind of like
so first one you know to make this
non-zero you have to make sure that this
variable is show up in the top right if
the variable doesn't even show up on the
top there's no partial derivative the
partial derivative will be zero so so
this is only non-zero only if
this wig does show up in the top so when
w i j shows shows up on the top only if
um
K is equal to I
right so that because only w k is
something show up on the top and w i j
so only I I and J are the same are I and
K are same then w i j can show up on the
top
so so that's why you only have to care
about those cases where K is equal to I
so you just uh the entire sum is gone so
you only have to care about
z i
and then
so you have maybe like I'll just do it
slowly so this is
wi1 times E1 plus up to W ID times UD
plus b i
over d w i j
okay so w i j only show up once here on
the top linearly so w i j show up here
on the top in this term
um
somewhere in the middle right so there's
a middle term which is look like w i j
times
u j that's the term that's W where w i j
shows up and the derivative of this
respect w i j is equal to u j
so that's why this is equal
um
this is equal to
sorry
times u j
right so so that's my
that's my DJ over dwij
and and then I have to group all of this
into a matrix form so if you're verified
that so basically you group all of these
answers into a matrix form it will be
like this
so you're gonna get all of this DJ
over dzi into this D J over D is equal
and in this UJ term will be grouped into
this U transpose
so so I guess I'm using a very simple
fact the simple fact is that
if something maybe let's say
um
x i j is equals to AI times BJ then that
means Matrix X is equals to A times B
transpose
that's the that's the simple fact I'm
using right so if some if the entry of a
matrix is equal to some AI times P J
then you can write it as Matrix form
where this Matrix X is equal to a times
B transpose a is a vector B is a vector
any questions
foreign
this abstraction
it's so called vectorized form of the
chain rule to a problem here
so what I got is that so what's the
mapping the mapping is that Z maps to Z
and the W one maps to w x map to U
right and J maps to J
so that's how I use this abstraction
so and after I use this objection what I
got is that I got
W1
DJ over dw1
is equals to
um
DJ over DZ times
U transpose will be X transpose
act transpose
okay
so
of course this is not done right because
we want to compute those but we we kind
of like we have a reduction in some
sense so we we did some partial work
right our goal is to conclude this but
now we said that you don't have to
compute this
DJ over DC and next I'm going to show
you how to compute DJ over DZ so it's
kind of like you are kind of peeling off
every a layer by layer in some sense of
course you can also do the same thing
for B
I guess the B is always easier so this
will be to see this
okay so so next question is how do you
do the
[Music]
okay let's see whether maybe I should
use the Newport
foreign so
so next I'm going to compute this
right from right the Z is DC so how do I
do this I'm going to have another
abstraction
so
um this is the abstract problem
so note that my Z
the the relationship between J and
between j and z is through this a and W2
right so there's some complicated
dependencies between j and z so I'm
going to abstract one part of it just to
make our
um kind of derivation clean so the
abstraction would be that you you think
of
um
suppose you have a variable a which is
Sigma of C
and then J is a function of a
so a sigma is this entry wise Sigma is
entry wise
kind of like a
activation function
right Sigma is the value basically
so I'm going to claim that in this case
you can you know that your target the
question you care about DJ over DZ is
going to be equals to DJ over D A times
Sigma Prime
Z
and this is a so I guess let me explain
annotation here so this is our and
dimensional vector
this is also n-dimensional Vector let's
say
in this abstract in z a they are all n
dimensional vector
so then this all M dimensional vector
and this is the so-called entry wise
entry-wise
product
right so I'm taking two undivision
vectors I take an untrust product and I
get the derivative I care about
so
okay
and and then you can see that the only
thing you have to carry you have to
compute next is what is DJ over d a
right because DJ over D is still I know
I'm not going to do this proof for this
it's actually even easier than the other
one you just have to expand and to the
channel
[Applause]
okay so now next let me try to
foreign
so how do I deal with DJ over da
I'm going to again abstractify
this part of computation in some
abstract form so my attraction is that
um so the abstraction
is that
um
I guess I'm going to have a is equals to
W Times U plus b
and J is equals to a function of a
right
um so why this is a reasonable
abstraction because a maps to this a w
Maps this W2
and this EU Maps wait am I doing
something sorry my bad
I have to use a different okay
maybe let's call this talk okay that's a
perfect place to call it okay
so tall okay so why this is a useful
abstraction this is because
the my thing in my mind is that tall
means
the the tall above
and on the W here means the W2 above
and B here means the B to above
and and J means the J
so know that the difference here is that
this W now means the second layer
right so and if you make this mapping
right so then what you care about is
that you care about DJ over d u here
because you or I guess I didn't say what
you corresponds to so U corresponds to a
right so U
corresponds to a
because a is
what is Multiplied with the Matrix right
so DJ over d u so that's what I care
about
so you can see that even though this
abstraction is very similar to this
abstraction the difference is that here
I care about DJ over d u I care about
the derivative with respects the input
of the Matrix fabrication
and before I carve our derivative with
respect to the the matrices
The Matrix in the matrix multiplication
so right so so that's why it's a little
bit different and you're going to have a
different formula for it of course
because you are taking derivative with
back to
um you know Y is respect to W and the
other is with respect to U
so okay so what's the formula for this
the formula for this is
um
if you write it in The Matrix form it's
w transpose times DJ over d
B D sort of
so I guess if you check the
dimensionality then
this one
okay I don't know what the dimension
here so I guess let me specify the
dimension so CW is maybe something like
um I don't know let me come up with the
maybe R times and
right so an U is of Dimension m
and Tau then has to be intervention on
so Dimension R sorry
so then this is in dimension r
and this double transpose is in
dimension
n by r and that's why they can be
multiplied together
of course you know okay I guess another
thing is that if you don't want to
remember all of these equations you want
to remember is so first of all you don't
have to remember all of them second if
you want to remember them and you want
to kind of cheat a little bit you can
just view the mask scalars and you can
see then so for example this one would
make a lot of sense if there are scalups
right that's just the the tribute to
rule and this one makes a lot of sense
if they're all scalars because you want
to take the derivative U with respect to
U then
W have to show up as the coefficient
so so everything make a lot of sense if
it are scalars and the only tricky thing
is that if there are matrices then you
have to figure out what's the right
transpose if you might left multiply
right multiplies and so forth
Okay so
okay so once I have this thing then I
can
um apply this to the special case above
right if you apply it then what you got
is that you with this mapping that you
got you
DJ over da
is equals to W2
transpose times
uh
DJ over dtau
right
that's because
um right just I'm just replacing the
note I'm just applying this General
thing to this case
and now you see that there's only one
thing that is missing what is DJ over
detail and that's trivial right because
DJ over D tall is just this is really
just the very last thing j is just the Y
minus Tau Square so DJ already told like
everyone can compute this is just a
I think minus y minus top
so
so what you really do you know
eventually then what you really do
eventually is that you first compute
this maybe this is step one
and then this is step two you compute DJ
over da then then
where DJ over Dia is used and then DJ
over Dia is used to here so then you do
this step three
and then you get DJ over DZ
DJ over DZ then used it
um here this is four
wait uh maybe four is here then you get
the derivative derivative with sector W1
so we really implemented you have to do
it backwards you know when you do the
derivation you know it's reasonable you
know we can do here anyway but
um I guess I'm doing it in the
in this way from W to from the lower
layer to the top layer so from the the
first layer to the second layer but when
you really do the implementation you
have to first complete this and this and
one two three four
uh I guess I didn't compute the
derivative with respect to all the
parameters so so I'm going to compute 0
to respect to W and B1 what if you want
to compute the derivative with respect
to W2
maybe that's a good question to see
whether it's somehow digest this
what if you want to do the DJ or DWT
sure
[Music]
that the toe with respect to W2 and
so and which for example which
abstraction you need like I have lost
three things right one two and three
which might notice
yes
it's cracked so I guess
um the the I think you're gonna use this
because W2 is the Matrix right you care
about derivative with Vector Matrix then
you want to use this so
so basically
so if you care about
this
then you view this W2 is the W here
so I guess then you need a different
mapping so
I guess you need to use the first
abstraction
well first dilemma
and and then you're gonna say W2
corresponds to a w
and the U now corresponds to What U
corresponds to
the a here
and and B1 B2 corresponds to the B
um and and Z corresponds to
sorry not Z that
so the Tau corresponds to Z
so this is in the the right hand side is
in the abstraction and the left hand
side is in the in the real case I care
about
so so this means that this is DJ over
the tall
uh
times
I I had U transpose here now I had a
transpose here so I'm going to have a
transpose
and I also know DJ over D B2 is going to
be equals to DJ over D top
makes sense
foreign
because everything is a vector-wise
notation
um and now what if you do it for
multiple layers you'll see that
everything is to stay it's the same so
you basically you're just gonna
repeatedly use these two landmarks so
the three landmarks are three
abstractions
um I guess maybe I should
number them in some way maybe let's call
this
Lemma one
and then here I'm using lemon one
and maybe let's call this lemma2
and this is Lemma 3.
so so I'm going to for the Deep networks
I'm just going to use Lemma one two
three repeatedly and I'm going to get
the gradient
so that's the last thing in this core in
this lecture
foreign
Networks
so suppose you have multiple layers of
new light works you know
um
so then I guess using the same notation
as last lecture
the first layer is this
the second layer
is some value
times D1
sorry this is still the first layer this
is the activation and then you do the
second layer
you have W2
A1
plus P2
dot dot and you get a R minus one layer
which is value
of C
R minus one
and then
I say you have the
auth layer the r
which is equals to
WR times a r minus 1.
plus b r
and then finally you have a loss
I guess I'll just write the logs here
given that the loss will be J will be a
half times y minus ZR
Square
okay so that's my computation of the of
the loss function
you know
a sequence of matrix multiplication and
and the activation functions
so now I'm going to try to compute the
derivatives the the partial gradient so
first of all I'm going to compute
DJ
over d w
k
for some case later
so
how do you do that
yeah this is a little bit awkward
um
I guess maybe it's okay to
I I know all the you all know this is
deep nuts right so
better
yeah nothing different this is the the
same thing as in last time I'm just
recording the notations so and I want to
compute
a derivative with respect to case Matrix
so maybe that's a derivative respect to
W2 I think right so Source K is two
now how do you do it so if I do this
with respect to W2 then
um
the thing is that you want to use the
landmark right so the landmark
um level one I guess maybe that's the
most relevant because number one is
trying to take derivative with respects
with some w
so you just do some pattern matching you
want to apply number one so so what's
the the abstraction here that I'm
talking here is that if you
um okay so how do you do the pattern
matching so I guess you say that what's
the definition of c w k WK is involved
in this computation in the following way
so WK is involved
in the following way c k is equal to WK
times a k minus 1 plus
b k
this is hot WK is involved and then you
say I don't care about what happens next
I just abstractify the rest
so then this is pretty much the same as
the setting level one
right so then using level one
or you can you yeah using this or you
know actually you can call it no you
don't have to call it Lamar you can call
it a formal or something right so number
one tells you that
if you take the derivative with respect
to the Matrix
is equals to
the derivatives with back to
z k z k is basically the output of the
matrix multiplication so times
the input of the matrix multiplication
which is a k minus 1 here transpose
okay
so that means that I only have to take
the derivative with respect to
Z K right z k is basically some of these
you know intermediate variables right so
how to take derivative with back to Z K
so you need to think about you know how
ZK is involved in this competition right
so ZK is involved so
I care about this
and ZK is involved in the following way
I'm not sure
so DK is equals to
railu
um okay sorry
CK is involved you know directly in the
following way so AK is equals to value
of c k
and then J the loss is a function of a k
right that's the part that z k is
directly involved
because you first goes to the value you
get a and then you you do some
computation to get J
and then you can use the the so-called
MR2
so dilemma 2 will tell you that what is
the
DJ over DZ okay
so it's going to be something about DJ
over D AK
times
the
the value Prime Times of c k
this is gamma 2.
and the third thing is how do you deal
with AK
well what is the derivative respect to a
k
so if you don't know derivative is about
AK then you have to
see again see how AK is involved in this
whole computation so how does it how is
AK involved so AK is involved because AK
if you use a to complete Z again to use
a to confuse Z K plus one
right so if you look at that part so
basically
ZK plus one
is equals to some
w k plus 1 times a k
Plus
B K plus 1.
this is the the time the first time AK
is used and the only time AK is used and
then you say the rest of the thing is
abstracted as a general
thing
and then you say I'm going to use
now I'm going to use the Lemma 3.
because lemons 3 is also about Matrix
for vacation right number three is also
about Matrix modification but it's
trying to take the derivative with
respect to the input to the matrix
multiplication right so a is the input
right so
um so using lamba 3 I'm going to say I
guess maybe I'm not sure whether I
should also make a explicit map so if
you care about the explosive math then
it means that
AEK corresponds to the U there in lamba
3.
right so w k plus one
corresponds to W there
and B K plus one
corresponds to the B there and J
corresponds to J
I guess Z K plus 1
corresponds to
talk
right so I guess if you just Pat if you
keep Patty matching I think it's a
little bit difficult to see the map the
actually the probably the right thing
way to the right way to think about it
is that you think about the rows of
these things right so Z K plus one is
the output of the Matrix verification
AK is the input to the matrix
multiplication and double case the The
Matrix in the in the multiplication so
so that's how you easily map the rows of
them
and then
um so you get
this thing
is equals to w k Plus 1.
transpose
so and then oh sorry I think I have some
is this this should be
it should be
so then you can see that if you look at
this two
sorry this is pile I must
so if you look at this formula
and this formula
basically this is kind of like a
recursion in some sense right so so here
you are saying that
from
DJ Dak you can compute DJ ZK and here
from the
like a
yeah basically you can just recursively
use this tool to get all of them so I'll
just make it explicit so
um
so basically with all of this formula
you are basically you already complete
everything
um it's just I'm going to reorganize
this to make it a little clearer
so what you do is that you say you start
from the last layer
yeah
the last layer here
so you'll first compute
I guess you know maybe let me just
describe the final algorithm
so you first compute the so-called
forward path
so you compute
all all the the values of all the
variables
so in some sense I've already assumed
that it's completed implicitly before so
basically compute all the
um Z1
A1
Z2
A2 so and so forth
right so just by Computing all of this
network evaluating the loss you get
everything right so you get all the
variables
and then in the so-called backward path
you complete the gradient
so and the way you do it is that pretty
much like same as the two layer Network
you start with the
the last one so you first can compute
this
with the last layer and this is Trivial
because J depends on ZR just in a very
trivial way so this is just the minus y
minus ZR
right so this is our starting point and
now you recursively use both of this
to get all of the DZ of the DZ over d a
so you already have DJ over DZ oh sorry
DJ over dzr and then you can use that to
compute
uh
the previous one using this right so so
from this you can get
DJ over d a r minus one
using this formula
because we get this is w
if I can do it on the Fly correctly yeah
guys this is AR
transpose DJ of d
CR
right so you you remove the index by one
and you get to a
and then you can use the a
to compute the Z the D DZ over d a to
come with a DZ already a DJ over DC so
so this is number one this is number two
number three you you get
ZR minus one
which is uh equals to
um
minus one
right so so basically I have to do in
this iteration you
it goes from R to R minus one and then
you repeat right so then you can
you can repeat you can say
I guess maybe I shouldn't number them by
so maybe I should number this one by one
this piece two
2.1 2.2
or 3.1
um in the in the third round you get
a r minus two
using this equation maybe let's say this
equation let's call it two
let's call this one
so
to see you using
two and then you got
a z version
using
Hua
and you do this repeatedly
so you get everything about a and z
I never after you get everything about
ANC
so so basically after
turning
all the
everything like this
it's pretty easy to get the
the gradient with respect to with
respect to W because you can just say
is
using this maybe let's call this Ray
you can say this is equals to
right
okay
so I guess you can see that
I do need a forward pass because in my
backward path I do require
a bunch of qualities for example it does
require I know the quantity z r minus
one so I have to save all the easy
quantities A and R all of this in my
memory and then in the backward Parts
I'm going to use them
um so and why this is called backward
pass in some sense if you think about
the computational flow I guess
um I guess this is probably my last
point that I can make today so this is
kind of like um
it's the reason why it's called back
propagation is because you can view this
as
you can see that you are the the way
that you eat you change the indexes you
start from R and R minus one and you do
R minus two or mass three so do this in
a kind of a backward way so in some
sense if you kind of draw a
um kind of a computational graph or kind
of a flow of the computation I'm not
being very formal here but if you draw
it in some sense then you can view this
whole computation as you start with x
and then you have the Matrix
modification you need to use the weight
W1
and B1
I'll do some matrix multiplication and
you get Z1
right and then you do another metrics
Buffet maybe you do another a
maybe this is as
I say you this you got Z1
and you've got the activation
say activation and you get you get
A1
and then you do a matrix multiplication
uh with also W2
B2 and then you get Z2
and you'll do this repeatedly
until finally you guys ZR
and you've got the the last J
okay so this is kind of like the forward
pass
and and if you think about how how to
kind of like conceptually how do you
organize the information in this
backward algorithm and sometimes what
you do is that
um I'm just trying to visualize this but
you know of course I've everything of
all of this will be in computer so in
some sense what you do is that
um
you first compute
a derivative with back to this variable
ZR
okay and then you say okay how did you
get the Z you get a z by some matrix
multiplication right so let me say
this is by matrix summation location
where the input of this is a r minus one
right so and
um and so then you take this uh in some
sense from this you compute
the derivative respect to a n minus 1.
right that's the that's my step two
point
2.1
right and and then you just keep doing
this in a backward fashion so you you
figure out you know
where a come from AMS when I come from
Arc minus one from come from Z are minus
one
so that's why you do a backward pass you
say this is completely from
ms1
right that's my step two point okay
sorry I'm not numbering this correctly
so this is 2.2
that's messed upon step 2.2 right so and
now keep doing this
eventually eventually I got
Maybe
C1
right
so that's that's the so-called backward
back propagation is
and in the middle you can also compute
the derivative with resp to the W
so because the derivative with Vector W
is equals to something about a
derivative with raised to Z so basically
once you get this quantity
you know you can start from this
quantity to get the derivative with back
to w
uh R minus one I think or my spell r
on minus what
um and and then I you know every time
you get one more DJ over DZ then you can
get one more DJ over DW so from this you
can get DJ over dw1
so so that's why it's called back
propagation and maybe just to say one uh
I know we are running out of time just
one more word about this so so this is a
a kind of very sequential computational
graph
but but actually if you have like a more
complex computational graph right so
which is not like as sequential as this
you can do almost the same thing
basically you just write all this graph
and then you figure out you know how to
do the back propagation
and the way to do the back the general
way to do that function is exactly the
same you just run in the graph in the
backwards the only thing you have to
figure out is that how does this you
know
like like what's this relationship
basically this Arrow right so how does
the
the derivative with box a depends on Z
right so what's the derivative respect
to the input of this of this module of
this you view this modification as a as
a generic module let's say right so and
and the only thing you have to figure
out is that how do you write this
so-called backward function this
backward function takes in
the derivative with respect to the
output of this module and output the
derivative with respect to input of this
module
and and that's that's the so-called
backward function for example if you
write pie charts if you need to write a
new module basically you have to
implement the forward function and the
backward function the forward function
is how you get Z from a and backward
function is how do you get the
derivative with back to
a
given a hypothetical derivative with
respect to Z the hypothetical I mean
like just some vectors right you're
taking some some vectors and you get
some light results and this is the
function you have to implement for the
module and and once you have this module
then you can run like a then you just
everything else is systematic
yeah I think I should stop here okay
thanks